avec l'impact de la venue des ans et le
fait que les gens sont revenus à la vie
ils ont réinvesti dans de grands
bâtiments et ses appartements soit un ou
deux millions d'appartements
les gens sont venus rappeler le
centre-ville hiatus est et restera qu'on
voit là ici c'est le meilleur yann
clairay celle comédie musicale
le ballet ya combien de théâtre comme ça
ici donc on a peut-être simplement de
grands noms 7 et la fréquentation l
école est très importante les gens sont
très consommateurs de culture et j'ai
même pas compter sur fb non heureusement
tous les petits ce qu'on appelle les
collèges mais ça pour une population de
quoi de 3 millions d'habitants
en tout c'est disons 5 millions avec
l'agglomération avec l'ofppt
l'agglomération fait vivre tous étaient
entre sans compter les cinémas toussaint
qui a toujours une activité qui qui se
passe ici ça devrait donner vie à la
ville moi je suis très fier de ma ville
comme vous voyons